well this object is made from a single
sheet of paper and just cut loose like
this and bloody and can you hold this
flat please okay we shall call this the
first page so this flap is and above
what he's holding
now please release it you can hold it
like this and that's going to be the
second state okay this flap is below
what he's holding now you cannot go from
the first state to the second state
because he's in the way yeah and you can
you know go from the first to the state
second well if these are made of rubber
something flexible then I can stretch it
and pass it over his body and come back
underneath but it's not rubber and it's
real paper so you can't do this so you
cannot go from first second now please
close your eyes for for a moment and
okay you could keep it keep it closed
now I'm going to do something and open
your eyes what he went from the first
the second energy he was holding this
all the time he didn't let it go so how
did it happen that's really strange from
this state to this state well this is
always being held so let's do it with
eyes open this time can you hold it
again now you can keep the eyes open
first I'm going to roll it like this and
that's like the pair of handcuffs or if
you want you can think of circle here
and I'm imagining another imaginary
circle which makes it in for us and I
mathematicians like to say I reversed
orientations of both generators of the
torus loop so the torus and I do this
and then that keeps the orientation I'm
on the other side we're coming up the
other side and yes indeed we're on the
other side so that tells us this is
indeed a Mobius band does it make a
practical house oh I think we oriented
like that there our house it taught us
slanted like the towers in Madrid for
instance right so that's nothing novel
there probably would have to either run
the elevator at an angle which you can
certainly do is a special track